Speaker 1: All right.
Let's take a little tour through the mind
of MAGA.
Donald Trump holding this rally for Mary Miller
in Mendon, Illinois.
Over the weekend.
We looked at some of the things Donald Trump
had to say.
We talked a little bit about things Mary Miller
has said.
Let's now look at the attendees.
And I continue to think that there's a bit
of a split between sort of like your normal
Republicans with whom I still disagree on
policy, but they're basically people who,
like on a weekend, they might, you know, go
to a tag sale or take their kids to soccer
or maybe, you know, even go to a shooting
range or whatever that there's those Republicans
and then there's the Republicans that are
willing to travel to a Trump rally.
And these are very different people.
I'm not saying I love the normal Republicans
political views.
That's not what I'm saying.
But but there is a distinction here.
And we're going to start with a guy who you
know what?
I'm not even we're just going to start with
a guy.
Okay.
Let's listen to what he had to say.
Speaker 2: Florida's an old neurotoxin that's
used to kill rats, and the Nazis used to put
it with Stalin.
They had a 1936 World Court.
We stop you right there.
Then why hasn't we've seen a lot of people
drop dead like rats?
Speaker 1: That's a great question.
Why hasn't we've seen.
That's exactly the question I would ask.
Speaker 2: And brushing their teeth or fluoride
or using a C, if you give a low toxic dose,
see if you had a massive dose of fluoride,
you would die now in your tube of toothpaste.
It does say contact the emergency room if
you swallow up drops ice and actually has
that warning on the tube of toothpaste.
And there are thousands of visits every year
for over four days in toothpaste.
But that's a minor issue.
Putting it in the water.
Oh, God.
Do you know that that extrapolated study for
fluoride safety was very simply done with
topical fluoride on a tooth in a lavatory
ingesting for it was never studied, kind of
like the some one or two of the ingredients
of the vaccine.
So let's stop you right there, because I've
got a lot of people right now.
They're going, wait a minute, he just said
that if I swallowed toothpaste, you have to
go.
You're going to the emergency room.
Okay.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Now, normally it says if more then is used
for brushing, is swallowed, like I know it
doesn't even matter.
You let you know and I know that this is that
this these are completely closed forms of
thinking.
But what it actually says if more than is
used for brushing but put that aside.
Speaker 2: Do the toothpaste it says it on
the box.
Okay.
So, okay, fluoride of silence.
Let's push that aside.
Tell me how you got it.
Let me check Mercury.
We'll push that aside, too.
Let's push all chemicals on the chemical table
to the side.
Real quickly, how do expert on chemicals and
biological.
Oh, let's not talk about that right now.
I want to talk about how you got 15 million
Democrats to vote for President Trump.
Oh, on a handshake and my reputation of being
the holistic guru of the world shaking 15
million hands.
Speaker 1: So obviously that's very significant
mental illness.
And it's treated as normal.
It's treated as political discourse.
It's treated as these are the constituents
of a political movement, and we don't want
to stigmatize mental illness.
It's not about making fun of it, but it is
important to point out when you have a political
contingent that whose origins are a complete
disconnect from the real world.
So when we talk about, you know, there's gradations
of this, there's gradations.
The comet ping pong stuff that was that was
heavily influenced by complete paranoid delusions
being suffered by many of the people who were
promulgating that that stuff.
And it's all gradations thinking taxes should
be lower is not this this is on one end.
Right.
Thinking we should have a lower tax rate is
on the other and in the middle there's a whole
bunch of different stuff and much of it has
just become accepted as valid political discourse.
Very, very crazy stuff.
Here is one woman who was asked, What are
Trump's biggest accomplishments?
This is a big Trump fan.
It's funny that she even struggles to explain
what they are and.
Speaker 2: Ground here for everything that
President Trump did while he was in office
was what?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 4: Oh gosh.
I'll help in the military.
Speaker 2: And military seems to be a very
popular subject.
Speaker 1: I love how the interviewer is like,
there you go.
It's almost like dealing with someone who
can't think.
And then they come up with something, you
know, like, can you tell us what?
What year is it?
Well, it's.
It's 2020.
Two.
Yeah.
20, 22.
Good.
There you go.
I mean, he's he's treating her like she's
an invalid.
But the point here is they don't even know
why they like Trump.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
And allowing more prayer.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Allowing more prayer and helping the military
are the big accomplishments of Trump.
Here is a gentleman who claims to be former
law enforcement who his big thing is gun rights.
Speaker 2: I'm just gonna tell you, I'm retired
law enforcement.
Hey, I'm a I'm a lifetime member of the NRA.
Yeah, I'm all about the Second Amendment.
Speaker 3: I feel safe standing right next
to you, I'll tell you that.
Speaker 2: My next book.
I am all about that.
I'm all about the Second Amendment.
Speaker 3: And what do you think?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
You know, there's a special snowflake feel
to a lot of these Trump supporters.
And let me explain what I mean by that.
One of the things I've talked about before
is that to some degree, this entire narrative
that exists, it's characterized as being more
on the left of everyone is special and everyone
is, you know what, whatever.
That sometimes taken too far, it can sort
of create problems of self-centeredness and
etc. where like, yes, we're all individuals,
we all bring unique perspectives to the table.
Everyone deserves to have their ideas heard
and children should be celebrated.
Oh, that's all.
That's all true.
But at the same time, we're all one of 8 billion
people, and everybody has to kind of be part
of the collective.
And there's millions of people that fall into
every category.
And we sort of like need some balance when
you go too far.
One of the things that I get the feeling of
with some of these folks is they believe that
they they are completely unique and above
everything else, the law enforcement guy.
Listen, I'm a retired law enforcement and
the Second Amendment.
And this makes me unique in my support for
Trump and how I should be listened to.
This is the thing they criticize about the
left.
They go, Oh, all these leftists special snowflake.
Well, they kind of do the same thing as a
teacher who supports assault rifles.
I am here and I know that it is Trump that
we need.
Okay.
All right.
It's just another opinion among hundreds of
millions, like let's let's apply some healthy
skepticism to everyone's perspective here
to some degree.
Okay.
Then we go to the next guy.
This guy doesn't know what's going on.
I won't even introduce this.
Speaker 2: When they when elect left, media
went berserk over President Trump drinking
with two hands or walking slow down an icy
steppe.
Yes, guys.
Fallen up the stairs to airplane one airplane.
Speaker 1: One.
Speaker 2: Three times.
And and Putin is out ice skating and riding
horses and practicing their foreign affairs,
which are really poor right now, but with
with a weak leader.
The worst.
Speaker 1: All right.
So anyway, Putin is strong and Trump is strong,
but Biden is weak.
That seems to be the most important perspective.
And then here's another woman asked about
again, about Trump's biggest accomplishment
in office.
And she struggles to these these folks are
struggling.
Speaker 2: Favorite thing that Trump did during
his tenure in the White House was what?
Speaker 3: It's one thing to.
Speaker 2: Put you on the spot for this one.
I'm sure there's I mean.
Speaker 3: I feel like he really brought our
country together for once.
I mean, I can't think of president, at least
in my lifetime.
That's brought us together as a whole.
Like that.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Remember how united the country was under
Trump?
That's that.
That's that's pretty.
Pretty interesting.
So sometimes I wonder how these folks even
managed to feed themselves and many of them
raise kids.
I mean, that's that's the that's the incredible
thing.
But a very interesting and different political
constituency.
And the question will be.
Without Trump on the ballot in November, do
they vote with Trump gone from the White House
and not on the ballot?
Do they vote?
And do Trumpian candidates win in November?
Four and a half months and we'll have that
answer last.